hey there welcome to Conan O'Brien needs
friend and uh what are you laughing
about I don't know you know often when
you when you come right in with a hey
there son and I just exchange a look
like is he gonna make it through how's
this going to
go at best that makes me self-conscious
well that's even and I can't I can't
roll through you know oh no now we won't
look at each other well I might want I
might want to put up some kind of
curtain or something for the open and
then it slowly Rises so that can see
each other once I've gotten through the
open but I it is distracting okay sorry
and uh we need to run this like a
professional organization okay take it
again we won't do anything no no I just
want to tell you that uh hey
there welome to Conan O'Brien needs a
friend I do need a friend always in need
of a friend you can't have too many
friends actually not true you can have
too many friends yeah who just you know
if you had like don't you find that
sometimes like yeah you get to a certain
stage of life and someone is kind of
interested maybe in being your friend
and you think I'm all set I'm set until
the grave yeah the or unless some of
them dies the older you get the smaller
your circle needs to be I have told
people I like you you seem like a nice
person I would be your friend but I need
for one of my friends to die that's what
you told me yeah yeah no I but I didn't
say you'd ever be a friend no that was
just uh you I said that was the
acquaintance list yeah which is much uh
you could be an acquaintance of mine if
an acquaintance
dies
but Sona right do you agree with what
I'm saying you don't have room you have
you have twins you have Tac your husband
Tac texian you don't have name okay yeah
whatever no no not whatever that's just
not his name you can't just say whatever
do you know for years I thought that was
his name I know I think there's people
who probably think is it t Toran okay I
don't know I'm honestly asking you what
his last name is you know what his last
name I don't I don't know his last name
it's bran you God oh man okay well
anyway let's go back to the friend thing
okay what I'm saying is you have a full
plate I have a lot of You' got two
children yeah uh you've got Tac last
name whatever he wants to say it is okay
uh and then um you've got I know your
friends piss right yeah that's true
Christina who I've called Piss Veronica
Angie you know achs Megan Lindsay right
you have a lot of friends yeah so if
another person came along at this point
and said hey I want to be your friend
and have some time with you would you
tell them I'm full up no I wouldn't and
you know what I actually made a friend
recently and we went to the Huntington
Library together and we had a really
lovely day and we had lunch and it was
really nice is this an affair or a
friend no no she's my friend she's my
friend now we'll like text every once in
how you meet um she's Armenian she's a
comedian her name's Mary and she's
really funny and I you know we just ran
into each other at a lot of different
events and she's cool I like her do your
current friends resent at all that
you've taking on a new friend no but
friends don't think like that no that's
not how friends work they don't get mad
that you have more friends what kind of
friends do you have the people that
really like keep track of this stuff
okay really keep track of those are
friends yeah well that's all I have I'm
sorry but um no I don't want to share
you no I don't I well you understand
what I'm saying don't you Matt that at a
certain point you're set you've got your
friends You' got your yeah you've got
your friends like I don't understand all
I'm saying I'm open to more friends but
you got to be a banger you know what I
mean you really got to a real Corker
like you got to come in dancing right
you got to have real good Spiro Anu
memorabilia exactly you have to have a
loot that's in tune um you need to have
your together a lot of things I
love about wintertime so cold outside
you gather inside with your Chums yeah
your Bros highfive them yeah and you sit
around a crackling fire and you know
what you do what crack open a a cold one
that's it isn't it that's it it is it is
it is y and when you crack open a cold
one you better make sure it's Miller
Light ah the best one sit around there's
a roaring fire maybe we' just roasted
some chestnuts probably not no one does
that really no then they crack open a
Miller Light and it makes the
conversation kind of flow everyone's
happy you guys are talking about sports
we are talking about sports we're
talking about hockey we're talking about
highly we're talking about trucks we're
talking about cars we're talking about
things we enjoy and every now and then
we stop we high five and we have some
more Miller Light yeah and then it's got
that clean finish oh don't even get me
started on the clean finish and it's
only 96 calories 3.2 carbs per 12 ounces
again I did those calculations Mir light
Great Taste 96 calories go to
millerlite.com to find out delivery
options near you you don't have to go to
the store delivery options or you can
pick up some mirror light pretty much
anywhere they sell beer if you walk in
and they sell beer my guess is they've
got Miller Light celebrate responsibly
Miller Brewing Company Milwaukee
Wisconsin 96 calories and 3.2 carbage
per 12 O and that's how I feel which is
you can come to me you can ask me if you
want to be my friend but you got to
bring something to the table because at
this point I've you know you know my
friends I've got a big posy yeah you
know I've got a big I rolled deep with a
lot of friends yeah three to four people
why are we doing this
podcast so like is it though it's called
Conan O'Brien needs a friend but what
isn't what I think what should be
implied is let's see if you make it what
do you think the like series finale of
this podcast is is there a friend for
you do you bring one of these people in
and finally announce I've I've had you a
number of times you're the one you're
the friend oh so we should make it like
The Bachelor kind of like I should hand
a rose when this thing finally comes to
the end which I hope isn't for a long
long time months from now I I think I
should hand a rose or a slate of corn
beef are you going to have overnight and
then like go to their Hometown and meet
their families and stuff too I've never
watched these shows is that what happens
that's what happens when you say there's
an overnight do they have sex I mean
that's implied they have sex on
television cameras AR on no no the
cameras aren't on but it's implied and
there's like rose pedals on the bed and
then they're like you know they start
making out and is that sexy to have rose
petals on the bed I mean I personally
it's supposed to be rose petals right
what do you put on it I see I got I
up like succulents like Cactus
yeah for lies once I was trying to be
romantic and I went and there was just a
a
shrub there was a shrub that I saw near
The Ficus it was like a ficus and I just
pulled it out I remember when I I pulled
it out and then my hands broke out in
these big sores but then I just threw it
all over the bed and she said how is
this sexy and I said come on this is
what people do it's a shrub what
dirt do you have on this woman that you
got her to marry you I don't know I I
definitely married up did it have the
roots and like the dirt soil all over
the bed oh man come on that's s sexy and
also a traffic sign that was nearby it
said deer crossing and and it was Rusty
and that came out too no so that was
just up near the pillow yeah and then
the yeah the deer didn't no one was
slowing down for the deer the deer were
like this should be okay there's a sign
lump antler jelly all over the
place I love deer going it should be
fine 's a side and then the other deer's
like should we check that it's still
there and the first deer is like who
would move a deer crossing sign there's
only Shrubbery here there aren't roses
here I go with no peripheral
vision
W get your deer jelly antler jelly nose
jelly hoof jelly we've got it all oh man
come on don't kill the deer yeah that's
not sexy don't do the shrubs all right
now you tell now you tell me what humor
like that this was after we had already
had two children
nonsense fortunately my two kids had
already come along when I tried the
shrub hey threw a shrub on the bread
let's do
it